as this massive winter storm barrels
north millions of people are dealing
with dangerous wind ice and snow this
morning the brunt of the storm will hit
eastern Massachusetts this afternoon
parts of Boston could see more than a
foot of snow today with up to three
inches falling an hour Don Dahler is at
Boston Harbor where the low temperatures
are freezing the water there Don good
morning good morning yeah the snow has
just begun here in the Boston area but
we've already seen some amazing things
this is the USS Constitution the oldest
commissioned ship in the Navy but as you
can see Old Ironsides might as well be
called old icy sides today she is
completely encased in ice more than four
inches thick in some areas and that's
been a real problem in this area in fact
they had to suspend the commuter ferry
system affecting about 5,200 commuters
because of that ice and just south of
Boston there was a ferry dock that was
completely pushed up in the air because
of the ice forming underneath it now
coastal flooding is another major
concern here but not only the
possibility of flooding but also the
fact that high waves might actually be
throwing ice as projectiles causing a
lot of concern of course people in this
kind of a situation if there's a weather
system they're also adventurers out
there and yesterday there was some
surfers out experiencing something
called slurpee waves those are waves
that are thickened by the ice and the
slush Boston mayor Marty Walsh didn't
tell people to get off the waves but he
did ask people to get off the roads they
want to clear these with the plows and
the salt trucks so there's five hundred
miles of streets in the Boston area and
they want to make sure that those are
safe for everybody but of course the
biggest concern are these winds we've
been hearing about they're expecting
anywhere between 25 and 65 maybe even 75
mile an hour winds along the coast and
the Cape that of course raises the
specter of power outages and with the
temperatures plunging to zero degrees
the real concern is heating their homes
in this area Alex John thanks I can say
with confidence I will never be one of
those surfers